IN SESSION- I'M GONNA ASK OUR
COMMITTEE SECRETARY TIFFANY
MORRISON TO CALL THE ROLL. DALY
HERE DALY HERE MAYES BERMAN
BIGELOW. BIGELOW HERE CALDERON
CALDERON HERE CHEN COOLEY
COOPER COOPER HERE FRAZIER.
FRAZIER HERE GIPSON. GRAYSON
GRAYSON HERE RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ HERE VOEPEL VOEPEL
HERE EVERCORE. WE HAVE A QUORUM
AND- MISTER BRADFORD IS- THE
BACK OF THE CHAMBER TO PRESENT
THE FIRST BILL SB SIX FIVE
FIVE. REGARDING- DIVERSITY GO
AHEAD SIR THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR YES I'M HERE TO PRESENT
SB SIX FIVE FIVE WOULD SIMPLY
LOWERS THE THRESHOLD FROM A
HUNDRED THOUSAND A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS TO SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION AS IT RELATES TO
INSURANCE COMPANIES GOVERNING
BOARD AND SUPPLIER DIVERSITY.
IT REQUIRES INSURANCE COMPANIES
PROVIDE DISCOVERING BOARD
DIVERSITY POLICY STATEMENT ARE
MEASURABLE- DIVERSITY GOALS AND
LASTLY DEFINES VERSE INVESTMENT
MANAGERS AND THE POINT PROGRAM
AND SB SIX FIVE FIVE BUILDS
UPON THE DATA PULLED- FROM
INSURERS AND USHERS TO
IMPLEMENTATION OF MEASURE WILL
GOALS IN DIVERSE INCLUSIVE
INVESTMENTS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE TODAY WE HAVE
MICHAEL MARTINEZ SENIOR DEPUTY
TO A COMMISSIONER- AND
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR DEPARTMENT
INSURANCE OR TO TESTIFY. GO
AHEAD MISTER MARTINEZ IF YOU'RE-
YES WITHIN EARSHOT THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. YES THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR GOOD MORNING
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MICHAEL MARTINEZ HERE ON BEHALF
OF INSURANCE COMMISSIONER
RICARDO LARA AND THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE. WE'RE
VERY PROUD TO BE THE SPONSOR OF
THIS BILL AND THINK THAT THE
SENATOR FOR HIS LEADERSHIP IN
OFFERING THIS IMPORTANT
MEASURE. THAT INCREASES EQUITY
DIVERSITY AND TRANSPARENCY IN
CALIFORNIA'S INSURANCE MARKET.
THIS BILL BUILDS UPON THE
SUCCESS OF OUR PREVIOUSLY
SPONSORED BILL ENACTED LAST
SESSION SENATE BILL FIVE THREE
FOUR ALSO AUTHORED BY SENATOR
BRADFORD THAT CONTINUES THE
PROGRESS OF OUR NATIONALLY
RECOGNIZED INSURANCE DIVERSITY
INITIATIVE. AS THE AUTHOR JUST
CONVEYED UNDER THE NEW SEVENTY
FIVE MILLION MILLION DOLLARS
REPORTING THRESHOLD IN THE
BILL. THERE WOULD BE A MODEST
INCREASE IN THE NUMBER OF
COMPANIES REQUIRED TO REPORT
AND WE ARE ABSOLUTELY COMMITTED
TO ASSISTING THE SMALLER
COMPANIES TO ENSURE THAT THEY
HAVE ADEQUATE TIME AND
RESOURCES TO PREPARE WHICH
INCLUDES PROVIDING
COMPREHENSIVE TRAINING SESSIONS
BY DEPARTMENT STAFF. ACTUALLY
IN FACT THE FIRST TRAINING WAS
HELD LAST MONTH AND RECEIVED
FAVORABLE FEEDBACK FROM THESE-
PARTICIPATING INSURANCE
COMPANIES. ALTHOUGH MANY
INSURANCE COMPANIES CURRENTLY
SHARE THE GOVERNING BOARD GOALS
AND POLICY STATEMENTS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT SAY WE DO CONTINUE
TO PROVIDE GUIDANCE AND I WILL
ABSOLUTELY CONTINUE TO. TWO
COMPANIES AND TO ASSIST THOSE
COMPANIES THAT HAVE NOT
PROVIDED GOALS OR STATEMENT IN
THE PAST. THE BILL PROPOSED
LANGUAGE PROVIDES COMPANIES
WITH FLEXIBILITY REGARDING WHAT
A DIVERSITY POLICY STATEMENT
UNTIL THINGS NOT MEANT TO BE AN
EXHAUSTIVE. LIST PLEASE NOTE
THAT- ALL THE BOARD DIVERSITY
SURVEY AND RELATED DATA A
REPORT OF THE DEPARTMENT IS
CONFIDENTIAL AND PUBLISHED BY
THE DEPARTMENT IN AGGREGATE
FORM. SO PLEASE KNOW THAT
THERE'S NO PARTICULAR COMPANY
OR BOARD MEMBER INFORMATION
THAT CAN BE INDIVIDUALLY
IDENTIFIED. WE DO MAINTAIN AN
UNWAVERING COMMITMENT TO
DIVERSITY EQUITY INCLUSION AND-
AND- BELIEVE COMMUNITIES WE
SERVE EXPECT US TO USE EVERY
POSSIBLE TOOL. INCLUDING THE
FULL SCOPE OF DIVERSITY
INCLUSION OF THE VERY PEOPLE
THAT SET AND DECISION MAKING
SEATS AND THAT ARE CONTRACTED
WITH. PROVIDE ESSENTIAL GOODS
AND SERVICES IN CLOSING I DO
WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE AND
THE STAFF FOR THEIR WORK- WITH
US ON THIS BILL AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUED
COLLABORATION WITH- THE
INSURANCE INDUSTRY AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS AS THIS BILL MOVES
FORWARD IN THE PROCESS. THANK
YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
RIGHT OF. THANK YOU MISTER
MARTINEZ. ARE THERE OTHER
PERSONS- IN ROOM ONE TWENTY
FIVE WERE HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM WHO WISH TO. OFFER
TESTIMONY. LET ME QUICKLY
REMIND THE PUBLIC THAT. YOU MAY
PARTICIPATE IN TODAY'S HEARING
BY CALLING. 877-692-8957 WITH
PASSCODE. TWO FOUR TWO SIX TWO
THREE SEVEN. OR BY VISITING THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE AT A. I. N.
S. DOT ASSEMBLY DOT CA DOT GOV-
LITTLE BIT MORE HOUSEKEEPING
TWO BEFORE WE PROCEED THERE IS
A MOTION AND SECOND AYE MR
BRADFORD'S BILL ACTUALLY WANT
WE JUST GO AHEAD. AND FINISH
THIS BILL- COMMITTEE MEMBERS
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS ON THE
BILL. WE DID GIVE AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS FROM MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC. THERE ARE NONE- THE
SHARES RECOMMENDING SUPPORT FOR
THIS BILL- ANY FURTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. THERE'S
A MOTION AND SECOND ROLL CALL
VOTE PLEASE. A GOOD IDEA
TIFFANY READY FOR ROLL CALL
VOTE. MMHM I ASKED I CAN ASK
I'LL ASK ONE MORE TIME THERE
SEEMS TO BE SOME CONSTERNATION
THAT WE DIDN'T. MAKE IT CLEAR
THATTHIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT. ANY PUBLIC
COMMENTS ON THIS BILL. GIVE IT
STRUCTURE OVER THE PHONE IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO HAVE ANY PUBLIC
COMMENT ON SB. EIGHT SIX SIX
FIVE FIVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. ONE AND THEN ZERO.
WE WILL GO TO LINE OF FORTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
THIS IS MARK MORALIS FROM CITY
NATIONAL BANK AND I- WORK
WITHIN PRIMARY CONTACT FOR
SUPPLIER DIVERSITY FOR THE BANK
AND I JUST WANTED TO. MAKE SURE
THAT YOU KNEW THAT CITY
NATIONAL BANK AND- AND OUR OUR
GROUP HERE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT SB SIX FIFTY FIVE I
ALSO SERVE AS CHAIR OF THE
DIVERSITY TASKFORCE AND I'VE
SEEN. THE DOLLARS THAT HAVE
BEEN COMING TO THE DIVERSE
COMMUNITIES JUST BY- REPORTING
UP BY THE INSURANCE COMPANIES
ON HOW MUCH THEY SPEND WITH
DIVERSE SUPPLIERS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR. THANK YOU AN
EXTRA LINE OF FORTY I'M SORRY
NOW GO ONLINE FORTY FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OTHER THAN
MANY VIETNAM CALLING ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA HISPANIC
CHAMBERS OF COMMERCE IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL. THANK YOU MISTER
DAVIS THANK YOUR NEXT. NEXT
OVER THE LINE OF FIFTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THE MORNING
CARE NUMBERS THIS IS MARK
MURDOCK OF H. ON BEHALF OF THE
BLACK LEADERSHIP COUNCIL IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR.
MEXICO LINE OF FIFTY SIX YOUR
LIGHT IS OPEN. HI THIS IS
SHANNON ROCK FROM THE PRESIDENT
OF THE ST PETER DEMOCRATIC CLUB
AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. AND AGAIN
WE'RE ON S. B. SIX FIVE FIVE.
AND THERE BE ONE ZERO FOR A
PUBLIC COMMENT AND NEXT WE'LL
GO TO LINE NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD LINE NINE. THEY TOOK
THEMSELVES OUT A Q. AND WE HAVE
NO FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT TO
QUEUE AT THIS TIME THE FUTURE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- ANY
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. THERE'S A MOTION AND
SECOND LET'S HAVE A ROLL CALL
VOTE PLEASE. FILE ITEM NUMBER
ONE SB SIX SIX FIVE IS DUE
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS DALY
AYE DALY AYE MAYES. MAYES AYE
BERMAN. BIGELOW BIGELOW AYE
CALDERON CALDERON AYE CHAN CHEN
AYE COOLEY COOLEY AYE COOPER
COOPER AYE FRAZIER. FRAZIER AYE
GIPSON GIPSON AYE GRAYSON
GRAYSON I RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ
AYE VOEPEL. VOEPEL I WOULD WOOD
I. BOB WHAT'S THE VOTE.
THIRTEEN THIRTEEN IS MISTER
BRADFORD THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN WAS BRIDGET BETCHA. ON
A WELCOME VICE CHAIR MAYES TO
OUR COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR
PRESENTING BILL OVER AND SENATE
INSURANCE A LITTLE WHILE AGO
ALSO I WANT TO WELCOME OUR
NEWEST MEMBER ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LISA CALDERON TO THE COMMITTEE
IT'S WONDERFUL TO HAVE YOU IN
THIS COMMITTEE- THERE EIGHT
BILLS ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
AND I THINK WE SHOULD. HANDLE
THOSE NOW. MOTIONS SECOND ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR- THEY'RE
LISTED CLEARLY ON OUR AGENDA TO
DO WE NEED TO LIVE DO WE NEED
TO VERBALLY. DISCUSSED THOSE GO
AHEAD. CONSENT CALENDAR FILE
ITEM NUMBER TWO SB SEVEN EIGHT
EIGHT BRADFORD DO YOU PASSED TO
FLOOR. S. B. F. R. FILE ITEM
FIVE SB TWO EIGHT THREE
GONZALEZ DO PASS THE FLOOR S.
B. R. FILE ITEM SEVEN SB THREE
NINETY. LAYARD DO PASTOR
PREPARATIONS FILE ITEM EIGHT.
TWO THREE TWO NIELSEN DO PASS
APPROPRIATIONS FILE ITEM NINE
SB ELEVEN RUBIO TO PASS THE
FLOOR. FILE ITEM NUMBER TEN SB
SEVENTY TWO RUBIO DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS. THE
I'M SORRY CORRECTION AT FILE
ITEM NUMBER NINE SB ELEVEN DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO THE FLOOR.
FILE ITEM- FILE ITEM NUMBER
TWELVE SB FOUR TWENTY AMBER. DO
PASSED AS AMENDED TO PUBLIC
SAFETY FILE ITEM NUMBER
THIRTEEN SB FIFTY EIGHT WELL TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS. DALY
QUESTION FOR STAFF- BEFORE WE
VOTE- IS IT A IS IT ACCEPTABLE
AT THIS POINT FOR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS TO ADD ON AS CO AUTHORS
ON ANY OF THESE CONSENT
CALENDAR BILLS. MISTER BIGELOW
WOULD LIKE TO ADD ON AS A CO
AUTHOR. ON SB ELEVEN BY RUBIO
IS THAT CORRECT MR BIGELOW.
GOOD ANY OTHER COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ARE ARRESTED AND BEING
A CO AUTHOR ON ANY OF THESE
BILLS. MR COOLEY SAME RUBIO
BILL GOOD GOOD. GOOD SO OUR
STAFF WILL NOTE THAT. GOING
FORWARD THERE'S A MOTION AND
SECOND ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
ROLL CALL VOTE PLEASE. YEAH.
MISTER GIBSON ADDS ON AS A CO
AUTHOR ON ITEM FIVE S. B. TWO
EIGHTY THREE. GOOD THAT'S
HANDLED. FRANK THE START OF THE
STAMPEDE YOU KNOW. YES IT WAS A
GOOD IDEA ALL RIGHT ANYTHING
ELSE SO IN TERMS OF CO
AUTHORING. NOW WILL VOTE ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. CONSENT
CALENDAR DALY AYE DALY AYE
MAYES MAYES AYE BERMAN. BIGELOW
BIGELOW AYE CALDERON CALDERON
AYE CHAN CHAN I COOLEY. COOLEY
AYE COOPER COOPER AYE FRAZIER
FRAZIER AYE GIPSON GIPSON AYE
GRAYSON GRAYSON AYE RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ I VOEPEL VOEPEL I
WOULD. WOOD I. THIRTEEN ZERO
THIRTEEN ZERO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR PASSES THE SENATORS WE
ARE WAITING ON OUR SENATOR
DORADO SENATOR GROVE AND
SENATOR STERN I'M TOLD THAT
SENATOR STERN WAS UNABLE TO BE
HERE AND THAT MR COOPER WILL BE
PRESENTING THAT BILL- SEND
SENATOR GROVE JUST WALKED INTO
THE ROOM LET'S GO AHEAD MISS.
GROVE. WITH YOUR BILL WHICH IS.
SB THIRTY NINE. FRAUDULENT
CLAIMS BY INMATES THIS AS AN
URGENCY BILL. YEAH THIS AS IN
IRAQ- FROM THE CHAIR. THANKS
FOR ASKING MIKE. I'M SORRY
MISTER CHAIR YEAH GO AHEAD
WE'RE READY FOR YOU OKAY THANK
YOU AT HAS A BILL ALREADY BEEN
MOVED OKAY THANK YOU SO BRIEFLY
SB THIRTY NINE- AIMS TO ADOPT
THE CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITOR'S
RECOMMENDATION TO PROTECT
TAXPAYER FUNDS WERE HELPING TO
ENSURE THE UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE BENEFITS ONLY GO TO
ELIGIBLE UNEMPLOYED.
INDIVIDUALS BY MANDATING THAT
THE EDG CONDUCT CROSS MATCHING
IT WITH CDC OUR RECORDS BUT
ONLY WITHIN NINETY DAYS THIS IS
A STATE AUDITOR'S
RECOMMENDATION AND TO BE BRIEF
THERE'S OPPOSITION THAT SAYS-
THE BILL INTENT IS TO GO AFTER
INMATES AND THAT'S JUST SO FAR
FROM THE TRUTH. THE IDEA OF
THIS BILL IS TO PROTECT INMATES
AS WELL AS SOMEONE'S USING AN
INMATE'S- SO SECURITY NUMBER TO
OBTAIN BENEFITS THIS BILL WOULD
ALLOW THAT TO BE CORRECTED AS
WELL AN INMATE TO BE ABLE TO
STILL PURSUE BENEFITS AFTER
THEY LEFT INCARCERATIONS I'M
GONNA BE VERY BRIEF INTRODUCED-
AS THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY FROM
KERN COUNTY WILL MAKE A BRIEF
STATEMENT THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME MISTER CHAIR AND I HOPE
THAT WAS. AT CONTENTED PRETTY
CLOSE HE WAS GREAT GREAT
SUMMARY. USER THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY- MISIMPRESSION SHOULD
BE ON THE LINE OKAY. I AM CAN
YOU HEAR ME. GO AHEAD GO HELLO
OKAY A GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIRPERSON AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME'S CINDY
ZIMMER AND I'M THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY OF KERN COUNTY AND I
AM SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF SB
THIRTY NINE A KERN COUNTY HAS
BEEN PARTICULARLY IMPACTED BY
EDT FRAUD BECAUSE OUR COUNTY
HAS BY STATE PRISONS. MORE THAN
ANY OTHER COUNTY IN CALIFORNIA
AND DURING A TIME IN WHICH WE
SEEN OUR CRIME RATES CRIED
ROCKET INCLUDING- HOMICIDES
WITH LIMITED RESOURCES BUT THEY
HAVE BEEN DIVERTED. TO THE
PROSECUTION AND INVESTIGATION
AT EDT FRAUD- THAT HAVE
OCCURRED NOT ONLY IN OUR
PRISONS IN OUR JAILS BUT OUT ON
OUR STREETS AS WELL AND FOR THE
LAW TO TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATED
WITH EDT FRAUD CONTINUES TO
CLIMB WE CONTINUE TO GET NEW
CASES AND WE'RE LOOKING AT
ABOUT THIRTY ONE BILLION
DOLLARS. IS ESTIMATED TO BE THE
LOSS OF TO CALIFORNIANS AND AN
UNMOLESTED CROSS MATCHING
REQUIREMENTS LIKE THOSE
PROPOSED HERE IMPLEMENTED
CALIFORNIA REALLY DOES CHRIS
MAKING THE SAME MISTAKES THAT
LEFT IT OPEN TO BE PICK
POCKETED BY CRIMINALS ON THIS
UNPRECEDENTED SCALE. ONLY
REALLY CLEAR THOUGH THIS BILL
DOES NOT INCREASE CRIMINAL.
PALIN PENALTY FOR THOSE
INVOLVED. AND THE BILL IS TO-
THAT THE CROSS MATCHING
REQUIREMENT IS PROPOSED TO
PREVENT THE FRAUD FROM
OCCURRING AT ALL. AND BY
SHOWING THAT THE NAMED
APPLICANTS WHO MAY OR MAY NOT
BE INVOLVED IN THE SCHEME IS IN
STATE PRISON AND NOT INDICT
TITLE TO BENEFITS. IT REALLY
CAN ACTUALLY WORK TO PROTECT AN
INMATE FROM BEING A VICTIM OF
IDENTITY FRAUD. BECAUSE IF THE
VICTIMS IF THE INMATES IDENTITY
IS USED WITHOUT THE INMATES
KNOWLEDGE HE TOO WAS A VICTIM.
BUT COSTS MATCHING CAN ACTUALLY
PROTECT THE INMATE AS WELL
BECAUSE IF HE DOES COM
UNDERSTAND SO HERE SHE COME
UNDER SOME SORT OF CLOUD- IT
COULD REALLY CAUSE PROBLEMS FOR
THE AND MADE IN THE FUTURE.
WHEN IT COMES TO PAROLE OR WHEN
HE GETS OUT ON THE STREET- SO
CROSS MATCHING REALLY DOES
PROTECT THE PUBLIC AND IT
PROTECTS THE INDIVIDUALS AS
WELL. AS FIDUCIARIES OF THE
PUBLIC TRUST WE OWE A DUTY TO
ENSURE THAT OUR TAXPAYER
DOLLARS ARE PROTECTED FROM
ABUSE AND FRAUD. WE URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT SB THIRTY NINE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISTER ZIMMER.
OTHER OTHER PERSONS WISHING TO
COMMENT ON THIS BILL. PERSONS
WISHING THE COMMON IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL EXCUSE ME. THANK
YOU ON THE PHONE LINES TO CARE
IF YOU WERE IN SUPPORT YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. ONE
AND THEN THEIR APPEARANCE BOARD
OF SB THIRTY NINE. AND WE WILL
GO TO LINE OF FORTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS IN A CALL FOR
COMMENT ON BEHALF OF SAN
BERNARDINO COUNTY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT OVER
THE LINE OF SIXTY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS AND SHAUN
MUTCHLER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF
SENATE BILL THIRTY NINE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU THANK AN
EXTROVERT SO LINE OF SIX. SIXTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THE
MORNING CARE MEMBERS
CHRISTOLOGY DAWSON WE HAVE KERN
COUNTY IN SUPPORT OF THE THIRTY
NINE THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AND
AS A REMINDER REAR ON BOARD OF
SB THIRTY NINE AND WE HAVE ONE
MORE INK YOU MISTER CHAIR ONE
MOMENT LET ME GIVE THEIR LINE
NUMBER. THAT COMMANDED THE ONE
AND THEN ZERO TICKETS UP INTO
Q. AND WE WILL GO TO A LINE OF
SIXTY TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ROBERT RIVAS CALIFORNIA CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE. IN SUPPORT OF SB
THIRTY NINE THANK YOU. MISTER
CHAIR WE HAVE NO FURTHER PUBLIC
COMMENT IN THE QUEUE THANK YOU
I WANT TO MAKE SURE WE GAVE ANY
PERSONS WHO ARE OPPOSED TO THIS
BILL AN OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY
ARE THERE ANY PERSONS OPPOSED
TO THE BILL. YOU WERE. IN
OPPOSITION OF SB THIRTY NINE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
ONE ZERO FOUR IN OPPOSITION AND
WE HAVE ONE PERSON IN Q. ONE
MOMENT HERE. THAT IS ONE AND
ZERO AND WE'RE ON BILL SB
THIRTY NINE. THAT'S ONE ZERO
WITH- OPPOSITION. IS THERE
ANYONE THERE THANK YOU WE WILL
GO TO A LINE OF THIRTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YEAH GOOD
AFTERNOON SHARING THREE MEMBERS
YOU ON YOUR BEHALF OF EIGHT OF
YOU CALIFORNIA ATION IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU AND WE
HAVE NO FURTHER OPPOSITION
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- THERE WAS A
MOTION BY MISTER GIBSON WAS
THERE A SECOND. ON THIS. MR
MAISEL SECOND IF THERE WAS NOT
A SECOND WE'VE A MOTION AND A
SECOND. MISTER BIGELOW AS WELL
QUESTIONS MR COOLEY OKAY- ANY
QUESTIONS BY COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
IF NOT LET'S VOTE THIS HAS
CHAIRS RECOMMENDATION OF DO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS ROLL
CALL VOTE PLEASE. FILE ITEM
NUMBER SIX SB THIRTY NINE GROVE.
DALY HI DALY AYE MAYES MAYES I
BERMAN. BIGELOW BIGELOW AYE
CALDERON CALDERON AYE CHAN AYE
CHAN AYE COOLEY COOLEY AYE
COOPER. COOPER AYE FRAZIER
FRAZIER AYE GIPSON GIPSON AYE
GRAYSON GRAYSON AYE RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ AYE VOEPEL VOEPEL I
WOULD. WOOD HI THIRTEEN ZERO
THIRTEEN ZERO THE BILL PASSES
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
VERY. THANK YOU SENATOR GROVE
FOR BRINGING A GOOD BILL
FORWARD- CENTER DORADO HAS
JOINED US SHE HAS TO BILLS.
THIS MORNING SB THREE THREE
FOUR AND THEN SB SEVEN HUNDRED
I'M GONNA ASK YOU MISTER MAYES
IF HE COULD- ACTORS CHAIR HERE
FOR A LITTLE WHILE AFTER GO OFF
AND- DO SOMETHING QUICKLY ALL
BE BOBBY BACK SOON. SENATOR
DRAWS- YOU'RE IN YOU'RE IN
MISTER MAZES HANDS RIGHT NOW
OKAY THOSE GOOD HANDS. OKAY.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN- I GUESS
I'LL START WITH THREE THREE
FOUR DOES THAT MAKE A
DIFFERENCE BUT THAT THAT WILL
WORK JUST FINE OKAY GREAT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I AM BEFORE AS HE'S WALKING NOW
TO REALLY WANT TO THANK THE.
OFFICE AND WITH THE SPONSORS.
TO COME UP WITH AN AGREEMENT.
THAT KEEPS THE SPIRIT AND
INTENT OF THE BILL AND
ADDRESSES. OF THE COMMITTEE
CONCERNED SO I AM ACCEPTING
THOSE AMENDMENTS. IT ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE WELL- THAT MAKES IT
EASY DOESN'T IT- I GUESS IS
THAT IT WE WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINES TO SEE IF THERE'S ANYBODY
THAT WISHES TO REPLACE. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF SB
THREE THREE FOUR YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. ONE ZERO YOU
ARE DEPORTED SB THREE THREE
FOUR. YES MISTER CHAIR. MICHAEL
MARTINEZ HERE ON BEHALF OF
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER RICARDO
LARA AND THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE AND- A
LOT OF VERY PROUD TO CO SPONSOR
THIS MEASURE AND THANK SENATOR
DORADO FOR HER LEADERSHIP IN
OFFERING THIS MEASURE I WILL
MAKE MY TEST MANY REALLY PRISON
AND HAPPY TO ANSWER QUESTIONS
OF COURSE AND I DO WANT TO SAY.
THAT COMMISSIONER A LOT- AND I
ALSO WANT TO THINK THAT SHARING
COMMITTEE STAFF WORK CLOSELY
WORKING WITH US ON THIS MEASURE
TO ARRIVE AT THIS AGREEMENT
HERE TODAY TO HOLD THESE-
FACILITIES MORE ACCOUNTABLE AND
PROTECT BASIC HEALTH SAFETY AND
HUMAN RIGHTS OF DETAINEES. AT
THE FACILITIES SO WITH THAT
SAID- RESPECTFULLY REQUESTED BY
THE- THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND I
GUESS WE SHOULD ASK- CENTER DO
YOU HAVE ANY OTHER PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. WAS THAT
YOUR YES- I HAVE A READ OF
MEDINA. STATE POLICY THAT THE
SIX ADVOCACY DIRECTOR FOR
CHIRLA. HI THERE CAN YOU HEAR
ME. YES WE CAN. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON OR GOOD MORNING AS
CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS
RITA MEDINA AND STATE POLICY
ADVOCATES NIGER AT COALITION
FOR HUMANE IMMIGRANT RIGHTS
YOUR CLIENTS YOU'RE LIKE THE
PRODUCT MARKET SB THREE THREE
FOUR. WE SEE THIS BILL AS
NECESSARY AND WILL REQUIRE A
MORE OVERSIGHT AND TRANSPARENCY
OF FOR PROFIT PRIVATE DETENTION
FACILITIES IN THE STATE WITH AN
EYE ON STANDARD OF CARE THAT
THEY HAVE AGREED TO THE
OPERATIONAL CONTRACTING
REQUISITE HEALTH SAFETY AND
INSURANCE REQUIREMENTS. SB
THREE THREE FOUR SIX TO ENSURE
THE HEALTH SAFETY AND HUMAN
RIGHTS AND VULNERABLE IMMIGRANT
DETAINEES. SEPTEMBER CONDITIONS
HAVE PLAYED BE FACILITIES FOR
MINIMUM HEALTH AND SAFETY
STANDARDS HAVE CONTINUALLY BEEN
VIOLATED THE MISCONDUCT IN
HUMANE CONDITIONS IN THE
FACILITIES ARE ALL TOO FAMILIAR
TO THOSE OF US WHO ARE ON THE
FRONT LINES WITH OUR COMMUNITY.
ACTION THAT OUR LEGAL
DEPARTMENT AND ARE ORGANIZED
THERE ARE IN CONSTANT
COMMUNICATION WITH COMMUNITY
MEMBERS SOME OF WHOM HAD DIRECT
EXPERIENCE. IN FACT THE
FACILITIES. THE BROWN SHOULD I
THOUGHT WE TREATMENT AND
RETALIATES. AND EXPOSURE TO
KIND OF. THAT ARE NOT UNCOMMON
HEAR. THE INABILITY TO HOLD THE
EXTENT OF CARE. BY FOR PROFIT
QUICKLY LIKE GOP'S AND
CORRECTIONS CORPORATION OF AN-
AND THE WORLD. OVER THE- FOR
EXAMPLE THE S. THE- OF JUSTICE.
SEVEN GENERAL FOUND IN TWENTY.
THAT PRIVATE. FOR IN. AND LESS
SAFE THE FEDERAL. NUMEROUS
OTHER REPORTS ABOUT THE
DISCOVERED AND CHANGE AND
DELIBERATELY. INDIFFERENT HER
THREE MEDICAL. AND DEPLOY
LIVING CONDITIONS. AND YOU CAN
ONLY EXACERBATED OVER THE YEAR
BY THE COOK AT NINETEEN
PANDEMIC WHAT WE LEARNED THAT
IMMIGRANTS IN THE FACILITIES
OFTEN LACK ACCESS TO SOAP.
SANITIZER MEDICAL SUPPLY PP AND
OFTEN A FACTOR INVIOLATE TION
OF SOCIAL JUSTICE STANDARD. THE%
NUMBER OF DEATHS IN IMMIGRANT
DETENTION CENTERS ARE ALSO
LEARN ME. AMONG THE FIRST
REPORTED OUTBREAKS LOOK AT
LOOKING AT THAT DETENTION
CENTER IN SAN DIEGO WE'RE AT
LEAST A HUNDRED ELEVEN PEOPLE
IN CUSTODY AND TWENTY FIVE
STAFFERS TESTED POSITIVE LAST
APRIL. AND WE'RE THE NATION'S
TOP FIRST BECAUSE IT NINETEEN
RELATED OUTBREAK EXPECTED IT'S
CRITICAL THAT THESE. FOR PROFIT
CORPORATIONS ARE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE AND COMPLY WITH
STRICT REGULATIONS RELATED. TO
HEALTH WELFARE AND SAFETY. THIS
COMBINED WITH A STATE. THAT WE
HAVE IN. OVER THE YEARS SB
THIRTY FOUR WOULD CAL. AND
PICTURE TO THE WHOLE OVER AT
THE FACILITY AT. WHEN CRITICAL
ENSURE THEY IN TO ALL MATHIS
HEALTH AND SAFETY. FOR THESE
REASONS RESPECTIVELY REQUEST
AND I FELT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
THEN LET'S GO TO A PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. IF
THERE ARE ANY. THE MODERATORS
ARE ANY PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. I AM A PO FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT. A WE CAN MOVE
TO PUBLIC COMMENT IF THERE IS
NOT A PRIMARY- WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION- I DON'T I DON'T SEE
NONE YOU'RE NOT DOUBT THAT
THAT'S FINE LET'S GO TO PUBLIC
COMMENT NOW AND IF I JUST YOUR-
NAME. YOUR ORGANIZATION AND
THEN WHAT HE SUPPORTER OPPOSE
THE BILL. THANK YOU FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO FOR. PUBLIC COMMENT
ONE AND THEN ZERO. AND WE WILL
GO TO LINE OF SIXTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS JUSTIN ROUTE
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
MIGRANT POLICY CENTER WERE PART
BECAUSE ONCE OF THIS BILL
ENERGY SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AND NEXT WE'LL
GO TO LINE OF THIRTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. YES HELLO THIS IS- HER
DISABILITY WAS CALIFORNIA AND
FONG BOARD OF SB THREE THIRTY
FOUR. THANK YOU THANK YOU AND
MEXICO LINE OF FIFTY SEVEN YOUR
MIND OPEN. HELLO THIS IS
JENNIFER POTS WITH THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL THANK YOU THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT ABOUT THE
LINE OF NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MORE MATURE MEMBERS RYAN
SHERMAN WITH THE RIVERSIDE
SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT TO VOTE ONE OF THIRTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS THE
ONES WHO ARE IN THE HOUSE OF
ACLU CALIFORNIA ACTION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AN EXTROVERT SO LINE OF TWENTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. JOHN
GLOBALLY FOR NORTHEAST
DEMOCRATIC CLUB LOS ANGELES AND
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND WE HAVE NO
FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT IN QUEUE
AT THIS TIME. WELL GREAT THEN
WE WILL COME BACK- TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR ANY. QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS- IT INFY MISTER GIBSON
I BELIEVE- CALLED FOR MOTION
AND WAS OUR SECOND WAS IT. WAS
THAT- THE NUMBER CALDERON- HOW
TO SECONDS OR ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. THERE ARE NONE AND-
WHICH PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
FILE ITEM NUMBER I GUESS I
SHOULD ASK IF YOU'D LIKE TO
CLOSE. MY GUESS IS YOU. JUST
ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS THANK YOU
THANK YOU THANK YOU SENATOR
FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE SB THREE
THREE FOUR DRAWS SO DALY. MAYES
HI MAYES AYE BERMAN BIGELOW.
BIGELOW NOW CALDERON WALDRON
AYE CHAN. CHANNEL THIRTY COOLEY.
COOPER COOPER I FRAZIER.
FRAZIER AYE GIPSON GIPSON AYE
GRAYSON GRAYSON I RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ AYE VOEPEL. VOEPEL I
WOULD. WOOD I. HAS NINE VOTES.
THESE ARE NINE THE AT THE NINE
VOTES SO WE WILL LEAVE IT OPEN
AND I DO SEE- THE CHAIRMAN IS
BACK- SO- WE'RE ON TO ITEM
NUMBER FOR MISTER CHAIRMAN.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
MAYES. GO AHEAD SENATOR DRAWS
ON YOUR NEXT BILL. MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF SB SEVEN HUNDRED-
I'M PROPOSING SB SEVEN HUNDRED
TO ENSURE THAT MISCLASSIFIED
PORT DRIVERS HAVE ACCESS TO
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE BENEFITS
AS WE BELIEVE THEY ARE ENTITLED
TO. AS A LABOR LEADER I SAW
FIRSTHAND THE IMPORTANCE OF
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE BENEFITS
TO FAMILIES WHEN A PARENT LOST
THEIR JOB. THE ONLY WAY THEY
CAN KEEP THEIR HOME AND KEEP
FOOD ON THE TABLE. FOR PUT PORT
TRUCK DRIVERS EVEN THIS MODEST
PROTECTION HAS BEEN DENIED. AS
THE PANDEMIC HIT THE AMOUNT OF
CARGO IN THE PORTS DROP MANY
DRIVERS FOUND THEMSELVES OUT OF
WORK. WHEN THEY APPLY FOR
BENEFITS THEY WERE DENIED EVEN
WORSE SO MISCLASSIFIED DRIVERS
WERE DEEMED TO BE EMPLOYERS OF
OTHER DRIVERS. MAKING THEM
LIABLE FOR UNPAID YOU I TAXES.
NOW WE KNOW THAT COMPANIES USE-
MANY WAYS TO MISS CLASS OF BY
WORKERS ESPECIALLY IN POOR
DRAINAGE. THE LABEL WORKERS A
SEPARATE BUSINESSES LEASE THEM
TRUCKS AND TELL THEM TO FIND
OTHER WORKERS TO DRIVE- OTHER
SHIPS. THE EDT DECISIONS THAT
ARE BEING MADE ARE BEING
OVERTURNED ON APPEAL. BUT
WORKERS SHOULD NOT WAIT THEIR
VERY SURVIVAL. DEPENDS ON
TIMELY ACCESS TO BENEFITS WHEN
WORK DRIES UP. THAT'S WHY MY
BILL SB SEVEN HUNDRED DIRECTS
EDT TO FOLLOW THE LAW. DIREXION
TO COMPLY WITH TWO KEY
DECISIONS OF THE CALIFORNIA
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE APPEALS
BOARD. THAT RIGHTFULLY FOUND
DRIVERS TO BE EMPLOYEES AND THE
TRUCK TRUCKING COMPANY. ARE NOT
TO BE THE EMPLOYER MUST PAY THE
TAXES. WE MUST ENSURE PORT
TRUCK DRIVERS GET FOR ACCESS TO
THE BENEFITS THAT THEY HAVE
EARNED. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. BOATS I HAVE TWO
WITNESSES CAITLIN VEGA AND
SHANE GUSMAN. THERE'S A MOTION
AND SECOND TO SUPPORT THE BILL
THE BILL HAS THE CHAIRS SUPPORT.
AND- LET'S GO RIGHT TO THE
PHONES WILL ALSO GIVE AFTER THE
PHONE WILL GIVE FOLKS WHO ARE
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM OR IN
ROOM ONE TWENTY FIVE AN
PPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY ALSO SO
WE'RE GOING TO THE PHONES RIGHT
NOW WITH SUPPORT WITNESSES.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR NUMBERS
KEEP IN VEGAS ON BEHALF OF THE
PORT DIVISION AT THE
INTERNATIONAL BROTHERHOOD OF
TEAMSTERS. HAVE CO SPONSORS OF
SB SEVEN HUNDRED. AND FIFTY
KENNEDY IS WELL AWARE OF THE
CHALLENGES AT EDT OVER THE PAST
YEAR- YOU HEARD A BILL A FEW
MINUTES AGO ABOUT FRIDAY EDT.
THIS BILL IS ABOUT ANOTHER
GROUP THAT IT WAS HURT BY SOME
OF THE ACTIONS THAT THE EDT AND
NOT SUPPORT TRUCK DRIVERS. WHO
HAVE HAD BENEFITS TONIGHT CAN.
KNOW WHERE HAD MATH
CLASSIFICATION OF WORKERS AS
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS BEEN
MORE PERVASIVE THAN AT THE
PORT. AND COURTS AND STATE
AGENCIES HAVE CONTINUALLY FOUND
THESE WORKERS TO BE EMPLOYEES
INCLUDING IN OVER FOUR HUNDRED
AND FIFTY CASES. BROUGHT BY THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR COMMISSIONER.
ADAM PLEASE THESE DRIVERS ARE
CLEARLY ENTITLED TO
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS. AND GET
THE EDT HAVE CONTINUED TO DELAY
AND DENY THEIR APPLICATIONS- WE
HAVE DRIVERS WHO HAVE BEEN
DENIED BENEFITS WE HAVE DRIVERS
WHO HAVE BEEN ACCUSED OF BEING.
EMPLOYERS OF ONE ANOTHER AND-
EVEN HAD THE EDT PURSUE THESE
NEXT CLASSIFIED DRIVERS. FOR
BACK WAGES AT BACK ON TAXES AS
THOUGH THEY WERE EMPLOYERS WHEN
REALLY THESE ARE THE WORKERS
WHO HAVE BEEN- EXPLAINED IT. AT
ALL OF THESE CASES EDT
DECISIONS ARE BEING OVERTURNED
SO THEY GET OVERTURNED BY THE
ALJ WHEN THEY GET OVERTURNED A
DELIGHT APPEALS BOARD. AND YET
THE EDT REFUSES TO CHANGE THE
WAY THAT THEY ARE MAKING THESE
DECISIONS- AND ARE NOT
FOLLOWING THE LAW. THIS IS A
SIMPLE DEL THE BILL BECAUSE
EIGHTY TO FOLLOW THE LAW. IT'S
BEEN CLEARLY LAID OUT IN THE
QUEUE REFERENCED- CASES BY THE
UAE APPEAL YOU AYE APPEALS
BOARD- IT BATTED CONSISTENT
WITH ALL OF THE DECISIONS THAT
HAVE COME OUT. THAT HAVE
ALREADY. EDT DETERMINATION. SO
THAT'S ALL WE. ASK FOR THAT
DRIVERS WHO NEED INTO- BENEFITS
HAVE ACT TO THAT AND THAT WOULD
CLASSIFY TRY WHO HAVE ALL-
ABUSED GAL AND- AND THEN TAKE.
BY WHAT THRUWAY AFTER NOT BE
AGAINST THE- BY THE E. D.
PERSONALLY NUMBER PACK THEY DO
NOT. THANK YOU MUCH. THANK YOU
MISTER. MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
GAS ON BEHALF OF THE K.
TEAMSTERS FOR CAN. IN SUPPORT
AND PROUD TO CO SPONSOR THIS
BILL- I WON'T O INTO TOO MUCH
DETAIL I THINK VEGAS AT
EVERYTHING THAT NEEDS TO BE
SAID OTHER YOU KNOW WE NEED TO
GET EDT TO FOLLOW THE LAW HERE
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT IT EXISTING
NOT LAW THIS BILL IS NOT.
REALLY CHANGING THE UNDERLYING
LAW WE JUST NEED TO GET THEM TO
DO. TO MAKE THE DETERMINATIONS
THAT THE LAW REQUIRES INSTEAD
OF GOING AFTER MISCLASSIFIED
DRIVERS STANDING UP TO
COLLECTIONS AND YOU KNOW.
HAVING THEM FACE FINANCIAL RUIN
OTHER THAN YOU KNOW INSTEAD OF
BEING WHAT HE D. SHOULD BE
WHICH IS. THE BACKSTOPS FOR
SOMEONE WHO LOSE THEIR JOBS SO
WE ARE YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU MR
GUSMAN ARE THERE OTHER SUPPORT
WITNESSES SO. WHO WISH TO SPEAK.
AND IF YOU'RE IN. GO AHEAD. IF
ANY STATE TAX A MINIATURE ON
THE ON THE FRONT LINES. IF YOU
WERE IN SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN
HUNDRED YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. ONE OF THEIR
APPEARANCE SUPPORT. AND WE WILL
GO TO LINE OF TWENTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GO AHEAD PLEASE.
FIND BY TWENTY NINE YOU HAVE A
GREAT MEAL. I'M SORRY IT IS
RANDY PERRY I WAS ON THE LINE
SUPPORTING THE PREVIOUS BILL
NOT THIS ONE- BATH PORAC I'M
NOT SURE WHY HUNCHES ****
ANYWAY- THAT'S AWESOME THANK.
WELL IN ANY CASE THANK YOU NEXT
WILL GO TO HEAR FROM YOU. THANK
YOU I THANK YOU. WE'RE STILL
ACCEPTING TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT
OF SB SEVEN HUNDRED. S. NEXT
ABOUT A LINE OF FIFTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI THE
MORNING CARE MEMBERS JESSICA
DURHAM LAWCENTER KLEIN FROM THE
KANEMI STRONG COAST- CONFRONT
THEIR IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. GINETTA LINE
SEVENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
MY NAME IS GOOD AT THE END OF
THE THREE IS- WAYS I'M LOOKING
OF INACTION CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN
HUNDRED. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
YOUR NEXT OVER LINE SEVENTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS
IS SHANNON ROCKWOOD ST PETER
DEMOCRATIC CLUB PRESIDENT AND
WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. YOUR NEXT
TO LINE FIFTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI GOOD MORNING I AM
ORTEGA WITH SO CALLED COSTS AND
WE SUPPORT SB SEVEN HUNDRED.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. YOUR NEXT
OF A LINE OF SIXTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS RON RAPP
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN HUNDRED
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. TO THE
LINE SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI MELANIE PRESS FIVE ON BEHALF
AND JOB MEREKA IN STRONG
SUPPORT YEAH. THANK YOU. ONE
TWENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS REGINA SK
ON BEHALF OF EARTHJUSTICE IN
STRONG SUPPORT. NEXT OF A LINE
OF FORTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. JOINT SWAPPING WITH ST
GEORGE EPISCOPAL CHURCH AND
QU'UNE CLERGY LAITY UNITED FOR
ECONOMIC JUSTICE IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. SO THE LINE
OF TWENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS DAVID
GARCIA WITH THE CORD- AND WE'RE
IN THE PORT OF THE STUFF. YOUR
NEXT TO A LOT OF TWENTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS IS
AMY FROM FARMWORKERS CENTER WE
ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. THANK YOU. OF A LINE OF
TWENTY SEVEN YEARS LINE IS OPEN.
HI THIS IS JON GLOBALLY FROM
THE NORTHEAST DEMOCRATIC CLUB
OF LOS ANGELES WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT. YOUR NEXT TO THE LINE
OF SEVENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS MARK
KRAUSS LABOR CHAIR OF
DEMOCRATIC SOCIALISTS OF
AMERICA LOS ANGELES AND STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE NOW FOR
THE SUPPORT QUEUE AT THIS TIME.
ARE THERE ANY OF PERSONS IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL EITHER
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM. OR IN
ROOM ONE TWENTY FIVE. IF NOT
LET'S GO TO THE PHONE LINES FOR
ANY OPPOSITION. GIVE IN
OPPOSITION OF SB SEVEN HUNDRED
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
ONE AND THEN ZERO FOR ANY
OPPOSITION. AND WE HAVE NO
OPPOSITION IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME MISTER CHAIR. COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ARE THERE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS ON THIS BILL. IT HAS
THE CHAIR'S RECOMMENDATION OF
SUPPORT- SENATOR WOULD YOU LIKE
TO WRAP UP ON THE BILL. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND JUST ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS THANK YOU
THANK YOU. I WANNA THANK THE
SENATOR FOR WORKING WITH THE
COMMITTEE STAFF AND MYSELF. TO-
ADJUSTER AND FINE TUNE THE
LANGUAGE OF THE BILL IT'S A
GREAT BILL AND- I RECOMMEND
SUPPORT. AND WE HAVE A MOTION
AND SECOND SO LET'S HAVE A ROLL
CALL VOTE. FILE ITEM NUMBER
FOUR SB SEVEN HUNDRED DORADO.
MOTION IS DO PASS
APPROPRIATIONS DALY OUR DAILY
AYE MAYES. MAYES AYE BERMAN.
BERMAN AYE BIGELOW. WE WILL NOW
CALDERON CALDERON AYE CHAN.
CHEN NOW COOLEY. COOLEY AYE
COOPER COOPER AYE FRAZIER.
FRAZIER AYE GIPSON GIPSON AYE
GRAYSON GRAYSON AYE RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ AYE VOEPEL. VOEPEL
NOW WOULD WOOD I. ELEVEN ELEVEN
AFFIRMATIVE VOTES SENATOR THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU THANK
YOU MEMBERS. THE LAST BILL ON
THIS AGENDA IS A S. B. TWO
EIGHTY FOUR BY SENATOR STERN.
YOU'RE LIKE YOU KNOW THE COURT
YEAH I IT WAS A NOT REALLY
OKAY. LET'S CLARIFY THE TO. MR
MAYS. WAS IN A NOT VOTING ON
THAT LAST BILL. SB SEVEN
HUNDRED WE'RE CLEAR ON THAT
TIFFANY GOOD. GOOD. AS I SAID
MR STERN- WAS UNABLE TO JOIN US
SO HE SENT A NICE LETTER
REQUESTING OUR ASSISTANCE IN
PRESENTING THE BILL AND MISTER
COOPER STEP FORWARD SO PLEASE
GO AHEAD SIR THIS IS A SB TWO
EIGHTY FOUR AND ENJOYS THE
CHAIRS. RECOMMENDED SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
BURST- SINISTER APOLOGIZES FOR
NOT BEING HERE. HE'S OUT IS
DISTRICT ON BUSINESS- FIRST THE
AUTHOR BE ACCEPTING THE SUGGEST
AMENDMENTS ON PAGE FOUR OF THE
ANALYSIS TO ENSURE THE BILL IS
PERSPECTIVE ONLY. AND APPLIES
ONLY TO INJURIES INCURRED ON OR
AFTER JANUARY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY TWO FOUR NEW GROUPS
ADDED. TWO YEARS AGO
LEGISLATURE PASSED IN THE
GOVERNOR SIGNED A MEASURE OF
CENTER STEARNS TO EXTEND A
POSTTRAUMATIC STRESS INJURY
RESUMPTION FOR WORKERS
COMPENSATION PURPOSES. TO
PUBLIC SAFETY OFFICERS
INCLUDING FIREFIGHTERS AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS TO HELP
GIVE THEM TIMELY ACCESS TO
MENTAL HEALTH TREATMENT. THIS
WILL BE FOR YOU TODAY BUILDING
THAT BIPARTISAN MEASURE BY
EXPANDING THE PROTECTIONS
OFFERED BY THE TRAUMA TREATMENT
ACTIVELY NINETEEN. DIVISIONAL
GROUPS OF FIREFIGHTERS AND
POLICE OFFICERS. IF WE THE BILL
EXTENDS THE PTS I PRESENTED TO
FIREFIGHTERS EMPLOYED BY. THE
STATE DEPARTMENT HOSPITALS. THE
STATE DEPARTMENT OF
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES THE
MILITARY. IN THE DEPARTMENT OF
VETERANS AFFAIRS. IT ALSO
EXTENDS PTS SITE PRESUMPTION TO
PUBLIC SAFETY DISPATCHERS.
PUBLIC FIFTY TELL COMMUNICATORS
AND EMERGENCY RESPONSE
COMMUNICATION EMPLOYEES. THE
TRUMP ACHIEVING ACT WITH A BI
PARTISAN EFFORT TO ADDRESS THIS
CRISIS IN SB TWENTY FOUR WILL
CONTINUE US ON THE PATH TO
ACHIEVING OUR GOAL OF.
FACILITATING TIMELY ACCESS TO
NEEDED TREATMENT. RAISING
AWARENESS ABOUT BILLS DROP
WAITED INJURIES. IN THE
STIGMATIZING THOSE CONDITIONS
FOR THOSE. WHOSE LIVES MAY
DEPEND UPON SEEKING TREATMENT.
WITH ME TODAY THE PHONE RYAN
EVERY THE CALIFORNIA STATEWIDE
LAW ENFORCEMENT ASSOCIATION AND
TINA BRAZIL PRESIDENT THE
CALIFORNIA HIGH PATROL PUBLIC
SAFETY DISPATCHERS ASSOCIATION.
ALL RIGHT SIR HELLO MISTER.
HELLO MISTER CHECKING HEARING
YES YEP YOU PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING MISTER
TURNER MEMBERS MY NAME IS RYAN
THE BAR WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATEWIDE LAW ENFORCEMENT
ASSOCIATION WE ARE PLEASED TO
SPONSOR SB TWO EIGHTY FOUR-
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT AND
WE ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THANK
YOU SIR. MISPERCEPTION YOU HI
MY NAME. GO AHEAD I AM HERE GO
AHEAD HI MY NAME IS TINA BRAZIL
AND- HI CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES WE
CAN GET ON YOU HEAR ME YES I'LL
GO AHEAD I NEED TO. KNOW I'M
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
HIGHWAY PATROL PUBLIC SAFETY
DISPATCHERS ASSOCIATION AS
SENIOR VICE PRESIDENT. OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATEWIDE LAW
ENFORCEMENT ASSOCIATION. AND WE
WANT TO THANK. THE COMMITTEE
FOR HEARING THE BILL TODAY AND
WE WANT TO URGE YOU TO HAVE A
YES VOTE ON SB TWO WAITING FOR.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT. ARE THERE OTHER
PERSONS WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. EITHER BY
PHONE OR BY- YOUR PRESENTATION
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM OR
FROM ROOM ONE TWENTY FIVE ANY
OTHER SUPPORTERS OF THIS BILL.
THE WORD SUPPORT OF SB THREE
FOR YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. ONE THEIR APPEARANCE
APART. AND WE WILL GO TO LINE
FIFTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE CRISTINA ALMA ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. NEXT OF A LINE OF SIXTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
THIS IS JENNIFER APPEARING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
FISHING GAME- ACCORDING TO
PROVIDE FOR THE MANAGERS
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT OF A
LINE OF EIGHTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF WITH MICHELLE BOWLER
WAY ERIN REID AND EFFECT YET
AND CORMAC IS IN FULL SUPPORT
OF THE BILL. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE NO
FURTHER SUPPORT QUEUE AT THIS
TIME. ALL RIGHT LET'S GO TO THE
OPPOSE. WITNESSES WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY- I HAVE A- FAITH MORGES
HERE ON THE LIST FAITH ARE YOU
THERE. YES MISTER KAREN HERE.
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR NUMBER EIGHTY FOUR JUST
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF JOINT POWERS
AUTHORITY IF WE AGREE WITH THE
AUTHORS RECOGNITION OF THE
HONOR AND DISTINCTION IN WHICH
PEACE OFFICERS SERVE OUR
COMMUNITY AND WE RECOGNIZE THE
MENTAL HEALTH CHALLENGES THAT
THESE OFFICERS MAY ENCOUNTER
BETTER HERE TODAY RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE AT THE TWO EIGHTY FOUR.
IN THE NINETEEN SEVENTIES AND
EIGHTIES MANY INSURANCE
COMPANIES WERE UNWILLING OR
VERY RELUCTANT TO PROVIDE
INSURANCE PRODUCTS TO PUBLIC
AGENCIES THOUGH PUBLIC ENEMY
RIC PULLING JPA BIRTH
APPLICATION AND AS A RESULT
MANY PUBLIC ENTITIES USE THAT
MODEL TO EFFECTIVELY FELL FUND
FOR WORKERS COMPENSATION
COVERAGE IN NONPROFIT JPA THE
BENEFITS PROPOSED BY SB TWO FOR
OUR TAX PAYER FUNDED IN MERRITT.
THOUGHTFUL RUBIO. ALL
PRESUMPTION EVEN READ.
ESTABLISHED IN NEARLY A- BAR
FOR AND TO ASK. EVIDENCE OF THE
NECK ADS MAKING PER. AS
CONCLUDES. SB TWO EIGHTY FOUR
PROPOSED TO IT THE- PRESENTS
CREATOR BY S. FIVE TWO. TO
ELECT OF CLASSIC. WHICH
THOUSANDS OF IT PEOPLE. THAT
INVESTIGATORS FOR THE DIP OF
CONSUMER AFFAIRS. EMPLOYEES AT
THAT OF HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT THE DEPARTMENT OF
MOTOR VEHICLES ANY PEACE
OFFICER EMPLOYED BY A K. TWELVE
PUBLIC SCHOOL AND MANY MORE. WE
ARE UNAWARE OF ANY OBJECTIVE
ANALYSIS THE DECLASSIFICATION
MARY ELIMINATION OF STATUTORY
CLAIMS REVIEW PROCEDURES THAT
ACCOMPANY WORKERS PTS WORKERS
COMPENSATION PTSD PRESUMPTION
OR THAT THEY'RE EVEN
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED BY
PTSD. IMPACTING INTERNAL REVIEW
OF CLAIMS DATA TELLS US THAT
PTSD CLAIMS ARE INFREQUENT AND
EVERY CLAIM THAT WAS RELATED TO
WORK WITH ACCEPTED IMMEDIATELY.
THE NIGHT OF THE STATE CLAIMS
THAT WERE APPROPRIATE AND MOST
CLAIMS DIRECTLY FOLLOWED A
DISCIPLINARY ACTION FOR AN
OFFICER OVER FILED RIGHT BEFORE
RETIREMENT WHICH SUBSTANTIALLY
INCREASES AN OFFICER'S. TAX
FREE PENSION BENEFITS.
CONFRONTING FOR INDIVIDUAL WHO
HAVE PTSD AND CALLER OBJECT
WHAT WE SHARE WITH THE OFF AND
THE- HOWEVER ME AND I'M- TAX
PAYER FUNDED THAT. BASED ON ON
JOBS HIGH IS NOT THE- AND
IGNORE NEXT POLICY AND FISCAL
TWO. WE WELCOME THE ADDITIONAL
REVIEW BY CATHOLIC DOCUMENTED
IN THE ANALYSIS I WOULD BE
HAPPY TO PARTNER WITH THE
AUTHOR IN THIS COMMITTEE ON A
BROADER CONVERSATION ABOUT
MENTAL HEALTH. AND PRESUMPTION
ELIGIBILITY THAT EXAMINES THE
IMPACT THAT SUCH CHANGES WOULD
HAPPEN INJURED WORKERS AND ON
LOCAL BUDGETS PRIOR TO FOR
THEIR COVERAGE EXPANSION
HOWEVER AT THIS TIME WE REMAIN
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE SB TWO
EIGHTY FOUR. THANK YOU MISS
BURGESS. MISTER SCHMELZER ARE
YOU- READY. YES SIR YES THIS
YEAR GO AHEAD SIR THANK YOU-
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS-
THIS IS TAKING SHELTER SHAGARI
ENTRY SMELTER AND LAYING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION ON WORKERS
COMPENSATION AND PRISM PUBLIC
RISK INNOVATION SOLUTIONS AND
MANAGEMENT I APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS MADE BY CA JOB ON THE
BROAD POLICY CONTAINED IN SB
TWO EIGHTY FOUR I WOULD LIKE TO
SPECIFICALLY FOCUS THE
COMMITTEE'S ATTENTION ON PAGES
THREE AND FOUR OF THE ANALYSIS
WHICH DISCUSS THE PRIOR
LEGISLATION SB FIVE FORTY TWO-
AND THE LACK OF DATA SPRINKLING
SUPPORTING THIS PARTICULAR
BILL. FOR THE BOTTOM OF PAGE
THREE- THE ANALYSIS IDENTIFIED
THE STANDARD FOR ESTABLISHING
THE NEED FOR A NEW PRESUMPTION
WE WOULD AGREE WITH THAT
STANDARD- THAT ESSENTIALLY
HOLDS ONE- THAT A NEW
PRESUMPTION SHOULD ONLY BE
EXTENDED WHEN THERE IS A TYPE
OF INJURY THAT MAKES IT
DIFFICULT TO ESTABLISH FOR
CONFIRMATION- INTO THAT THERE'S
DATA SHOWING THAT THAT TYPE OF
INJURY IS BEING DENIED BECAUSE
OF THE HARDSHIP WE THINK THAT'S
THE CORRECT TEST I WE WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASSERT THAT THE
PROPONENTS OF SB TWO EIGHTY
FOUR IF NOT PROVIDED ANY KIND
OF OBJECTIVE EVIDENCE THAT
WOULD MEET THAT STANDARD. THE
PRIOR BILL SB FIVE FORTY TWO
ALSO HAD NO OBJECTIVE EVIDENCE
THAT WOULD MEET THE STANDARDS
OUTLINED IN THE ANALYSIS THAT
BILL WAS MOVED FORWARD BUT WAS
HEAVILY AMENDED IN THIS
COMMITTEE- INTACT IT INCLUDES-
AT SUNSET- IN THE CHAIR
REQUESTED AN ANALYSIS FROM THE
COMMISSION THAT WAS INTENDED TO
PROVIDE AN OBJECTIVE BASIS UPON
WHICH TO CONSIDER THE EXTENSION
OF THAT PARTICULAR SUNSET THAT
RESEARCH IS NOT YET AVAILABLE
TO THE COMMITTEE THAT HAVE BEEN
REVIEWED BY EMPLOYERS AND WHILE
IT MIGHT SPEAK TO THE NEED TO
OR NOT- FOR THE FOR SB FIVE
FORTY TWO AND THERE IS NO
INDICATION THAT IT WILL SPEAK
TO THE VAST EXPANSION THAT'S
ANTICIPATED BY S. B. TWO EIGHTY
FOUR. THE ANALYSIS ACTUALLY
IDENTIFIED THE NEED FOR FURTHER
RESEARCH TO ADDRESS THE NEED
FOR THE LEGISLATION THAT YOU'RE
CONSIDERING RIGHT NOW WE WOULD
RESPECTFULLY SUGGEST THAT SB
TWO EIGHTY FOUR SHOULD BE A TO
YOUR BILL IT'S BEING ADVANCE
WITHOUT ANY SORT OF EVIDENCE
THE COMMITTEES ALREADY IN THE
PROCESS OF TRYING TO EVALUATE
THE VALIDITY OF THE PRIOR BILL
IT CAN'T BE CLAIMS THAT WERE IN
A HURRY TO FIX SOME SERIOUS
PROBLEM BECAUSE THERE'S NO
EVIDENCE OR DATA TO SUGGEST
THAT FACT- SO. FOR THOSE
REASONS I RESPECTFULLY WE WERE
YOUR NO VOTE TO- THERE'S NO RE.
FOR MARK. THE THIS CAN'T- IN.
IN THE- THREE. THANK YOU SIR
OUR THERE OTHER OPPOSE ITNESS.
ANYONE ELSE. HERE IN HERE IN
OPPOSITION OF SB TWO WAITING
FOR YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. ONE AND THEN ZERO FOR IN
OPPOSITION. AND WE WILL GO TO
LINE EIGHTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING TERM MEMBERS
CRYSTAL TO TALK ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY OF BEVERLY HILLS IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT OVER TO LINE
FIFTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
LINE FIFTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN DO YOU HAVE A SON YOU.
OKAY AND THEN WE'LL GO TO LINE
EIGHTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THIS IS YOUR MEMBERS SHARE
MEMBERS ABOUT HALF THE AMERICAN
PROPERTY CAT REINSURANCE
ASSOCIATION. ALIGNER COMMENTS
SUPPOSED TO MISTER STRUCTURE
IMAGE BORDERS IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU SIR. THANK YOU AN
EXTRA LINE TWENTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON RYAN
THROUGH THE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
AND OPPOSITION. THANK YOU OKAY
AND WE HAVE NO FURTHER
OPPOSITION IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME. COMMITTEE MEMBERS ANY
QUESTIONS ON THIS BILL I DO
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THAT THIS
BILL WILL SUNSET- ENOUGH THE
TWO AND A HALF YEARS FROM NOW
WHATEVER DATE THAT IS. THE END
OF. WHAT WAS THAT. THANK YOU
JANUARY FIRST OF TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE APPROXIMATELY TWO AND A
HALF YEARS- FROM TODAY IN
COURSE THE BILL WON'T BE
EFFECTIVE- IF IT IS SIGNED INTO
LAW UNTIL JANUARY. ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS ON THIS
BILL MISTER GIBSON. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN OF THANK
ONE SENATOR STERN FOR BRING
THIS THIS SENSIBLE BILL BEFORE
US AND THANK MR COOPER FOR
STANDING IN HIS STAT I JUST
WANT TO JUST BRIEFLY- INDICATE
AGAIN WE WERE CURRENT. WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THE FRONT LINE
INDIVIDUALS WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
OUR FIRST RESPONDERS WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT FIREFIGHTERS ARE
TALKING ABOUT POLICE OFFICERS-
AND I THINK THAT A NUMBER OF
INDIVIDUALS WHO- ARE INSURANCES
WORK FORCE ARMS YOU KNOW
SUFFERS IN SILENCE WITH- PS-
PTSD AND I THINK WE NEED TO DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO MAKE SURE
THAT THESE MEN AND WOMEN WHO
SERVE US AND PUT THE LINE ON
THE- PUT THEIR LIVES ON THE
LINE DAY IN AND DAY OUT. ARE
TAKEN CARE OF AND I THINK THIS
IS A STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION- AND I AGAIN WANT TO
COMMEND THE AUTHOR AND ALSO
MISSED COOPER FOR STANDING IN-
IN THE AUTHORS- STARED ON HIS
BEHALF OF BRING IT IS SENSIBLE-
THE MEASURE BEFORE US TODAY
I'LL BE SUPPORTING- WITH MY
VOTE. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT TO
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
MISTER COOPER A- DID A-
FABULOUS JOB PRESENTING THE
BILL WOULD YOU LIKE TO MAKE ANY
MORE COMMENTS SIR IF THAT WOULD
MISTER CHAIR- I'M HAVE A CENTER
STERN ONE THINK THE BILL IN
COMMITTEE THE MEMBERS AND
COMMITTEE FOR A HEARING THE
BILL AND JUST TO ADD IS THE
THIRTY YEAR LAW ENFORCEMENT
VETERAN I HAD PLENTY OF TIME TO
BE AROUND OUR DISPATCHERS TELL
COMMUNICATORS AND- MERCY
RESPONSE EMPLOYEES AND JUST
THINK ABOUT THIS- NIGGLES NINE
ONE ONE FOR ALL CALLS- A
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE VICTIM
BEGGING FOR HER LIFE AND THAT
OF OUR CHILDREN- SOMEONE'S LAST
WORDS IN A CAR CRASH. THE
VICTIM THAT'S BEEN SHOT DOWN BY
CALLING NINE ONE ONE A BEGGING
FOR HELP- IT'S TOUGH MEASURE.
SOMEONE'S LAST DYING WORDS. IN
THE THAT IS THE IS TOUGH ON
YOUR SOUL. TO DEAL WITH THAT
DAY IN AND DAY OUT IN THESE
TELL COMMUNICATORS DISPATCHERS
RECEIVED THOUSANDS AND
THOUSANDS OF CALLS DURING THEIR
CAREER. AND AT SOME POINT. IT
ADDS UP IT IN THERE IS TRAUMA-
SO IT'S LIKE I SAID. IT TO HAVE
THE MEASURE. I'VE EVER DONE IT.
ON THE PHONE LINE YOUR LAST
DYING WORDS YOU TRY TO GET HIM
HELP. SO IT'S SOMETHING THAT'S
NEEDED- I WANT TO THANK THE
CENTER FOR BRING IT FORWARD
AND- I THINK DOING IT- IT
OUTSTANDING JOB ON IT SO-
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU MISTER COOPER. I APOLOGIZE
TO THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS INTO
THOSE LISTENING I- MADE A
MATHEMATICAL ERROR WHEN I
MENTION THE SUNSET- AS TO HOW
MANY YEARS FROM NOW THAT WOULD
BE BUT SUFFICE TO SAY THE BILL
DOES SUNSET PROPOSES SENSITIVE
JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE. ANY OTHER COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS WE HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND. THIS IS A
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION. ROLL
CALL VOTE PLEASE. FILE ITEM
NUMBER ELEVEN SB TWO EIGHT FOUR
STERN MOTION IS DEEP PASSES
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS DALY
OUR DAILY AYE MAYES MAYES AYE
BERMAN BERMAN AYE BIGELOW IT'S
BIGELOW AYE CALDERON CALDERON
AYE CHAN. CHAN I COOLEY. COOLEY
AYE COOPER COOPER AYE FRAZIER
FRAZIER AYE GIPSON GIPSON AYE
GRAYSON GRAYSON I RODRIGUEZ
CAME IN. HEY GUYS RODRIGUEZ I'M
SORRY I VOEPEL WE'LL TELL I
WOULD WOOD HI. FOURTEEN
FOURTEEN FIVE VOTES ON THAT
BILL THANK YOU TO THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AND- WE'LL KEEP THE
HEARING OPEN FOR AWHILE FOR
ANYONE WHO WANTS TO ADD ON. I
DON'T THINK WE HAD ANY MISSING
MEMBERS DID WAS. WHO. OUR
MISTER BERMAN. TIME ADD ON MR
BERMAN CONSENT CALENDAR BERMAN.
BERMAN I FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE
SB SIX FIVE FIVE BRADFORD
BERMAN BERMAN I. FILE ITEM
NUMBER THREE SB THREE THREE
FOUR DRAWS THOUGH BERMAN.
BERMAN I DALY. YOU GOT IT ON
THIS ONE. I'M IN OUR DALY I.
COOLEY COOLEY I. FILE ITEM
NUMBER FOR SB SEVEN HUNDRED
ARISE THOUGH. WE GOT. FILE ITEM
NUMBER SIX SB THIRTY NINE GROW.
BERMAN BERMAN I.
THE HEARING IS
ADJOURNED.